bonsoir aujourd'hui à 15 avril 2015 dans
l'actualité yvelinoise l'institut
véhicules décarbonés communicants et
leur mobilité fait c'est un an depuis
versailles il regroupe des acteurs
industriels académiques et du monde de
la recherche autour de la conception de
l'automobile du futur bilans et projets
avec son directeur général invité du
journal la start-up yvelinoise wise up
en plein essor présentes sur le marché
du covoiturage domicile travail elle
vient de se voir décerner un nouveau
prix qui récompense son choix de miser
sur un partenariat avec les entreprises
et puis clôture de la semaine des
handicaps à elancourt pour le dernier
jour des associations sportives
mobilisés du côté de la clé de saint
pierre
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation et de
l'économie sociale aujourd'hui député
des yvelines benoît hamon attaque une
nouvelle fois le président hollande dans
une interview accordée à paris match et
publiée aujourd'hui il estime ce dernier
incapable de figurer au second tour de
la présidentielle de 2017 pour le parti
socialiste et demande une nouvelle fois
une inflexion plus sociale de la
politique menée et estime que bon nombre
des solutions portées par la gauche ah
non pas encore été tenté le gouvernement
qui vient en tout cas de voir son projet
de loi santé validé en lecture
solennelle à l'assemblée hier le texte
prévoit des paquets de cigarettes
neutres des étiquettes nutritionnelles
elle simplifiée sur les produits
alimentaires ou encore la création de
salles de shoot et puis elle la
généralisation du tiers payant d'ici à
novembre 2010 est que pensez vous de
cette dernière idée c'est notre question
du jour c'est pas très normal en fait
c'est pas les médecins qui devrait
avancer les frais c'est la sécu soit
savez habituel soit celle les patients
c'est pas les médecins je préfère comme
quand même garder leur régime actuel
certains disent qu'il y aura des abus de
certaines personnes donc je ne sais pas
j'ai pas vraiment d'avis sur la question
carrément pourrait bien sûr puisque on
avance plus d'argent et plus intéressant
je crois que c'est pas une bonne chose
pour les médecins je pense que ça leur
fait pas mal de passes de paperasserie
pardon et les généralistes de nos jours
on en a de moins en moins même en région
parisienne ne serait ce que sur
montigny-le-bretonneux y en a qui s'en
vont à cause justement de ce que la
sécurité sociale veut leur imposer donc
je serais plutôt de leur côté sur ce
coup là ouais oui parce que je trouve
que c'est normal que les gens n'aient
pas à avancer d'argent
le texte de loi sur la santé doit
maintenant être adopté par le sénat en
procédure accélérée s2 verte est chose
faite d'ici à juillet elle santé et
toujours avec le recrutement d'une
quinzaine de médecins territoriaux dans
les yvelines par le conseil
départemental afin d'assurer des
missions de consultation mais aussi de
participer à la prévention et à la
protection de l'enfance candidature à
envoyer à l'adresse mail qui s'affiche à
l'écran les postes sont à pourvoir à
plaisir trappe mantes-la-ville les murs
ou encore montfort l'amaury et
versailles
le conseil départemental qui embauchent
mais qui annonce également devoir faire
des économies le vote du budget aura
lieu ce vendredi la baisse de la
dotation de fonctionnement versée par
l'état inquiètent 165 millions de pertes
soit 17 % des recettes globales la
priorité sera donnée au déploiement du
très haut débit pour tous au
développement d'un cadre de vie de
qualité et à l'accompagnement et des
grands projets d'infrastructure propice
à l'attractivité des yvelines souligne
pierre bédier le président les
déclarations d'impôts c'est en ce moment
du moins par internet ouverture du
service ce matin l'an dernier sur les
quelques 37 millions de foyers fiscaux
en france 13 ont effectué leur
déclaration de revenus par ce biais
bercy pousse pour que la déclaration en
ligne deviennent progressivement
obligatoire sur quatre ou cinq ans en
commençant par les plus hauts revenus
une fois encore les télédéclarants
dispose d'un délai supplémentaire la
date limite est fixée pour eux dans les
yvelines au 9 juin pour ceux qui
continuent à opter pour une déclaration
papier l'échéance est fixée au mardi 19
mai on laisse de côté la finance pour
l'innovation avec notre invité antoine r
bonsoir en fait c'est le directeur
général devait d comme vd comme qui fête
son premier anniversaire vd comme pour
véhicules à décarbonés communicants et
leur mobilité installé à versailles et
pour faire simple vous ambitionnez
d'être le leader européen en matière
d'innovation dans les domaines des
véhicules électrifiés des véhicules
autonome et connecté le véhicule de
demain le véhicule du futur alors un an
après le passage en institut pour la
transition énergétique
avez vous réussi votre pari est vous le
leader européen aujourd'hui au nom mais
malheureusement on l'ambitionne on a un
an de vie réellement on a la chance
d'avoir été incubés pendant quatre ans
par le pôle de compétitivité mov'éo donc
c'est un peu un départ lancé vives qui
nous supportent tous nos fondateurs ne
supporte le conseil départemental des
dividendes et à supporter donc
maintenant on est dans la vraie vie on
démarre il ya déjà des bonnes réussites
mais c'est tout début on va parler ses
réussites c'est un partenariat public
privé on vous l'avez souligné
département des yvelines les
agglomérations ce soit versailles grand
parc encore saint quentin en yvelines du
côté des entreprises parce que les
constructeurs les groupes les pme jaune
je participe aussi bien sûr donc on a la
chance d'avoir des grands groupes comme
renault psa mais également des
équipementiers valeo et puis d accueil
et d académie de renault qui nous
supportent qui nous ont toujours
supporter donc une constance dans le
domaine comment ça se passe concrètement
votre travail ce soir ce sont des des
chercheurs de ces différents groupes que
ce soit psa que ce soit à renault qui
met à disposition des chercheurs vous
comme comment s'élaborent les projets
elle comment vous travaillez là on
travaille d'abord tous ensemble c'est
une particularité je remercie d'ailleurs
versailles de nous accueillir c'est une
espèce de
l'immeuble dilution il ya effectivement
des cadres supérieurs de psa renault des
thésards des
designers qui travaille tous ensemble
une collectivité alors il ya des projets
qui sont déterminés donc on a une vraie
feuille de route mais néanmoins la
créativité se fait au petit déjeuner au
café al interposés je crois que c'est ce
qui fera la force de great wall il ya
des réalisations concrètes justement on
était représenté lors il ya un certain
nombre d' abord de résultats déjà deux
thèses qui sont déjà disponibles il ya
déjà eu des rapports qui ont été
établies mais maintenant on va plus loin
trois grands projets en cours le premier
sera li té ce bordeaux on aura un
deuxième très gros projet qui arrivera
en juillet prochain sur le site de
satory pour nous ancrer au niveau du
territoire avec un atelier de
d'électrification là ça sera vrai de
quoi définitivement cet incident mais en
2010 où les plus tôt début 2010 16 se
veut on sera chez nous vous êtes c'était
donc la première année d'exercice à
cette occasion un véhicule aussi a été
présenté à versailles la semaine
dernière regardez ce reportage et puis
détail tout ça juste après
cette voiture électrique conduite par
anne charlotte nico a une particularité
elle peut aussi se conduire sans
chauffeur un véhicule totalement
automatisées bourré de capteurs qui
prennent tout en charge à la place du
conducteur
un peu à l'image d'un être humain la
voiture conduire a besoin de percevoir
son environnement où sont les capteurs
de perception qui vous seront là donc
celle ci a une vision à 360 degrés afin
de minimiser le risque d'enlisement
voire même supprimer complètement
elle a besoin également de se localiser
on se sent le but des capteurs de
localisation puisque vous avez besoin de
savoir où vous êtes et qu'elle est
l'environnement autour de vous et enfin
elle doit prendre des décisions son
appel le module de supervision sont
quittes l'intelligence embarquée et tout
le coeur de nos algorithmes ce véhicule
prototype est l'une des grande fierté de
bd comme il est testé sur les pistes de
satory l'institut de transition
énergétique a été lancé il ya un an il
travaille sur toutes les questions de
mobilité d'électrification
d'automatisation et de connectivité des
voitures du futur on a les grandes
entreprises de l'automobile française
qui son fondateur de bd comme des grands
instituts de recherche et puis également
des pme et bientôt des start up donc
c'est un écosystème de près de 40
membres qui travaillent ensemble tous
les jours un mariage entre secteurs
public et privé entre petites et grandes
entreprises entre chercheurs et
ingénieurs qui porte ses fruits
aujourd'hui l'institut emploie un peu
moins de 100 personnes ils seront plus
de 150 à la fin de l'année et les prévu
encore une centaine d'embauchés d'ici
2016 pour fonctionner vd com il fait
partie du pays a le plan
d'investissements d'avenir dispose d'un
budget de 19 millions d'euros ce budget
est en croissance donc sur trois ans et
l'ensemble de bd comme est financé à 10
ans pour
globalement une centaine de millions
d'euros quand l'état met un les
industriels mettent 1 ça c'est le
principe de base du financement de bd
comme reste une interrogation à quand
une voiture sans conducteur sur route
pour l'heure c'est interdit en france et
en europe seul l'état du nevada aux
états unis a donné cette autorisation
pour la google car mais l'avenir
s'annonce radieux pour vider comme en
octobre prochain la ville de bordeaux va
accueillir le congrès mondial des
systèmes automatisés et les responsables
en sont persuadés les derniers levier
législatif devrait se lever en attendant
vd comme travaille également sur un pôle
d'excellence qui ouvrira la fin de
l'année à satory pour réparer cette fois
les moteurs électriques de demain
ce salon mondial dédié au transport
intelligent qui va se tenir à bordeaux
ça va être un tournant parce qu'il ya un
blocage un blocage législatif a été
évoqués dans le reportage moi je crois
que bordeaux c'est avant tout une
démonstration c'est pas de
l'exploitation donc évident et comme
pour d'abord objectif c'est de fournir
des briques technologiques et
effectivement d'essayer de déverrouiller
en fait les verrous qui permettrait de
ne pas le faire donc pour la
démonstration bordeaux le véhicule
autonome la prime rien priorité c'est la
sécurité donc effectivement on sait
aussi l'occasion avec avec l'état il ya
une commission
interministérielle qui travaillent avec
nous pour nous donner à l'occasion de
bordeaux des autorisations qui vont nous
permettre effectivement déroulé suivant
les conditions que l'on sait les talents
de rassurer les pouvoirs publics
assurent éventuellement les assureurs
hausse et surtout nous rassurer et
rassurer les clients qui achèteront des
voitures qu'on ne mettra aucun des
véhicules dans la rue sans avoir
validé l'ensemble de son de son
dispositif sécurisé le but de vider
comme quand on voit le véhicule
prototype qui a été présentée c'est pas
au final de commercialiser ce genre de
prototype c'est de permettre les
technologies l'utilisation des
technologies par tous vos partages et a
placé fédérer donc l'objet que vous avez
vu c'est en fait un laboratoire roulant
qui permet d'accueillir l'ensemble de
nos partenaires et de te capter la
meilleure technologie française pour
pouvoir ensuite le en faire une synthèse
qui soient effectivement robuste pour
pouvoir leur donner en fait à ceux qui
vont industrialiser ses véhicules
indépendant autonome en tout cas on peut
les imaginer pour caen sur la route je
crois que le mieux c'est de le poser de
poser la question aux constructeurs
puisque c'est bien eux qui le convertit
à lison donc nous on va fournir et je
pense que dans le domaine c'est très
exponentielle ils sont les briques
technologiques déjà s'avancer connaître
ces prêts ça dépend de quel niveau où
vous pouvez entrer entre une voie privée
une voie publique suivant les vitesses
que vous évoquez il ya une roadmap les
aléas déployé il y aura des cas
facile qui seront disponibles
certainement assez rapidement elle avait
des comme le projet on parle d'un an
d'activité un véritablement mais c'est
un projet sur une dizaine d'année 1 à
tout à fait ce n'est absolument pas le
court terme c'est un investissement long
terme c'est pour ça que les partenaires
nous nous finance l'état aussi n'ont pas
suffi pour investir donc on investit
dans la durée et c'est pour ça qu'on
sent très vite --moins satory à
versailles pour y rester avec des moyens
physiques il faut que ça soit pérenne
département des yvelines c'est le
premier département automobile de france
45 % des emplois automobiles
d'ile-de-france 150 entreprises du
secteur générant près de 45 mille
emplois qu'ils sont à implanter et pour
garder ce dynamisme en tout cas éviter à
la filière de s'effondrer et pour le
département c'est important vd comme
prend tout son sens aussi c'est pour ça
qu'il faut s'implanter dans les yvelines
et c'est pour ça que vous êtes là oui
parce qu'on est un écosystème
extraordinaire il ya la vallée de
l'automobile iaa le grand paris tout ça
bouge on a déjà 100 personnes donc au
sein de bd comme l'objectif 250 dans
donc quasiment deux ans donc ça y est on
est là et on a tout l'écosystème autour
de nous pour réussir écosystèmes
environnement ça veut dire aussi
environnement bien sûr c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille aussi sur des véhicules
électriques n'est pas uniquement faire
du véhicule autonome c'est faire de
l'éco mobilité et la multimodalité
prochaine étape l'installation dans les
nouveaux locaux ça aussi ça va changer
beaucoup de choses oui je sais elle aura
des attaques avant
c'est quoi votre calendrier parce qu'à
l'étranger aussi on s'intéresse au
projet bd comme par exemple il ya eu une
demande des autorités brésiliennes aussi
auprès de dvd comme moi je prends notre
objectif aujourd'hui cette façon c'est
de capter l'intelligence où se trouve
une intelligence et de trouver les
meilleurs
l'excellence à l'endroit où ils se
trouvent on est ancré sur le territoire
et c'est un exemple sera pas de
travailler effectivement avec les
intelligences diverses dans le monde la
france est à la pointe de toutes ces
technologies que ce soit sur
l'écomobilité que ce soit elle sur les
véhicules autonomes je pense que la
france n'a absolument pas à rougir je
pense que l'urgence c'est d'aller vite
ne pas se disperser mais je pense que la
france a aujourd'hui techniquement tous
les atouts pour réussir et
financièrement il est comme une
structure pérenne malgré les difficultés
financières que sur les dotations de
l'état qui soit diminué on parlait tout
à l'heure du conseil départemental qui
va devoir trouver de l'argent ailleurs
aussi bas pour l'instant l'anniversaire
a été un bonheur pour nous des mots ont
été prononcés on vous aime et en fonte
et l'amour c'est la déclaration et
l'amour c'est fini aussi effectivement
donné des signes d'amour et je pense
qu'on a un certain nombre de signes
d'amour qui font que pour l'instant je
suis assez peu assez rassuré vis-à-vis
de la pérennité de dexia la structure
merci de nous présenter mike est menée
depuis un an par avait des comme le
véhicule du futur pas forcément pour
demain mais après demain c'est quasiment
sûr merci à vous focus sur une
entreprise à présent hier dans les
locaux d'hilti à magny les hameaux se
tenait la remise des prix du world tour
un défi lancé à part une application de
covoiturage interentreprises mélanie
poquet et william l il est passé de
mains en mains ce petit klaxons c'était
la mascotte du world tour le moyen de
prouver qu un covoiturage avait été
effectuée le world tour c'était le défi
lancé par une jeune start up pour
développer le covoiturage
interentreprises with up tour ses 15000
personnes qui ont été impactés par la
communication on a à peu près 200
nouveaux inscrits sur la plateforme
c'est environ 700 messages échangés et
c'est surtout 30 nouvelles personnes qui
se sont mis à covoiturer sur 50 ha en et
vela trois entreprises étaient
concernées le technocentre de renault le
crédit agricole et l'entreprise
d'outillage en bâtiment hilti on avait
l'occasion
d'avoir des voisins un renault et snecma
qui eux aussi qu'aux voitures est avec
enfin voulait covoiturer avec ce site et
ça c'était la première raison la
deuxième raison c'est que en fait with
up est quand même un site bien adapté au
covoiturage domicile travail montre ag
boula au travail c'est un plaisantin
autour de 20 km pour moi c'est un petit
peu fatigant du coup c'est bien de
trouver quelqu'un part déjà avec lui ce
trajet là on partage
des choses avec parfois on se raconte
des histoires la vie personnelle un
petit pot russie pour le travail près de
trente mille utilisateurs sont
aujourd'hui référencés sur toute la
france sur saint quentin en yvelines
huit personnes sur dix trouvent un
covoitureur
transport toujours mais du côté des
aménagements routiers des nouvelles du
chantier du doublement de la rd 30 à
plaisir à compter de ce vendredi des
travaux d'aménagement du futur pont de
la rue jules renier vont démarrer pour
une durée d'environ 15 mois le pont de
25 mètres de long permettra de franchir
la rd 30 à l'emplacement du carrefour
actuel la circulation sera maintenue une
petite déviation sera toutefois mise en
place
culture jean louis poitevin un signe un
ouvrage consacré exclusivement à la
sculpture de haine nicolas sanhes saint
quentinois originaire de rodez une
géométrie incidente c'est le titre de
cet ouvrage qui retrace une carrière
longue de près de 30 ans catherine
château et patrick jacq de 10 km
un livre rien que sur l'oeuvre de
nicolas sanhes deux ans d'écouter
d'observation pour le critique d'art
jean louis poidevin une géométrie
incidente le titre de ce livre pour
retracer le travail si particulier du
sculpteur qui modèlent la sicom
personnes auparavant
effectivement il ya une invention
ayant égalé il ya un style il ya quelque
chose quand il n'y a aucun autre
sculpteur français on pourrait mais même
si on regarde et les sculpteurs qui vont
utiliser en partie les mêmes matériaux
mark di suvero par exemple on va bien on
va bien voir que non les questionnements
ne sont pas les mêmes il a posé une
véritable question jusqu'où peut-on
aller dans l' équilibre dès lors que
l'on est en jeu des force
incommensurable
avec cet équilibre je veux simplement
aller jusqu'au bout ce que je peux faire
aujourd'hui et demain je prenne un cran
plus loin parce qu'il sera demain j'aime
cette idée de de se donner pleinement
dans ce qu'on fait
là ça c'est comme ça que je pense à
les choses demeurent exigence parce qu'
abandonner j'ai bien compris que je
pouvais être aussi à la limite de ma
propre vie
nicolas sanhes travaille seul dans son
atelier saint quentinois il dessine et
calculs il expérimente il monte il
regarde lui le natif de rodez né de
parents agriculteurs reproduit sur
l'acier décision de son enfance venant
de la terre chez besoin d'avoir ce
contact direct avec la matière pour et
c'est aussi une réponse pour que la
structure ce qui relie on travaille
depuis le début c'est la ligne alors se
mettre la ligne qui est celle qui est
tracée par une herse de vin champ et
initie un paysage et lorsque j'étais
étudiant cas je tenais grand tableau
noir j'ai en fait je inconsciemment
j'essaie de retrouver ça
ce livre retrace 30 ans de carrière un
accomplissement dans la vie d'un artiste
même si rien est encore fini il ya
plusieurs façons de faire de le faire de
l'argent il ya des gens qui travaillent
d'une manière spontanée ou impulsive moi
je pense que une véritable oeuvre d'art
elle se passe de notre temps de l'alluré
d'un temps et pour cela il faut tout
faire de l'art en face avant tout il
faut se comprendre je sais pas ce que
le temps me réserve de l'espace vont
travailler
mais en tout cas chaque minute est
consacré
dans le cadre de la semaine du handicap
la ville d'elancourt a proposé plusieurs
des animations de sensibilisation samedi
dernier c'est l'équipe éducative de
l'ifab d'elancourt qui a organisé une
journée de sensibilisation des changes
principalement autour du sport pour
répondre à toutes les questions que le
public peut se poser mélanie poquet et
florane parfait
se déplacer en fauteuil pas facile quand
on n'est pas habitué on dit qu'ils
vivent mal en fait il est bien connu
mais juste un petit peu moins bien parce
que je trouve un peu compliqué c'est
voici cessé de fonds ouais c'est essayer
de tourner dans tous les sens
sensibiliser au handicap de manière
ludique c'est tout l'intérêt de cette
journée organisée par l'association
insertion formation éducation prévention
d'elancourt pour l'instant c'est
deschamps qu'ils abordent pas trop parce
que la plupart d'entre eux n'ignore pas
mais bon ils ont il ya des jeunes qui
sont ces hommes dans le cap sur le
quartier mais il les considère pas
forcément quand on est handicapé on va
dire s'il ya un tabou autour du de ces
moulins pour lever un peu de 7 à bout le
public principalement composée d'enfants
a pu s'entretenir avec des personnes en
situation de handicap ce qui est marrant
c'est le regard des enfants il faut quoi
tu peux y aller avec les bras et les
jambes cassées donc ils comprennent pas
qu'on est handicapé et le handicap c'est
compliqué de trouve que gdf fr te fait
découvrir le handicap de faire voir
autre chose que des handicapés
qui ne bouge pas donc faire découvrir le
monde de notre cap à travers le sport en
2012 la fédération française handisport
comptait plus de 31000 licenciés à
travers la france
chaque année dans plusieurs communes de
france dont celle de magny les hameaux
des opérations de nettoyage de printemps
sont organisés le moins que l'on puisse
dire d'année en année c'est que la
quantité et la nature des détritus ce a
toujours de quoi surprendre mélanie peau
qu'elle a constatés
le beau temps n'était pas au beau fixe
ce matin là mais pas de quoi décourager
les 32 bénévoles manie quoi venu donner
un coup de propre à leur commune sacs
poubelles gants et chaussures de marche
ils partent pour une heure sur deux
circuits forestier et un urbain pense
qu'il ya plus de gens qui devraient
participer moi je suis étonné qui est
bon il ya quand même déjà quand même pas
mal de monde mais j'aurais pensé qu'il
ya plus de gens effectivement les poèmes
c'est que c'est la majorité qui
qui jettent des papiers des canettes ça
et c'est pas eux qui vont venir ramasser
en fait papiers bouteilles sont les
principaux déchets mais parfois les
objets collectés sont plus inhabituel
mise en place depuis une quinzaine
d'années cette initiative permet de
compléter le travail d équipe municipale
les services techniques le font à
longueur d'année
mais on ne peut pas aller par exemple
dans les
fossés dans les bas-côtés entrer dans
les dix premiers mètres de la forêt
voilà donc là les équipes hamas sur un
peu plus large que les bords de routes
et de chemins les détritus collectés ont
ensuite été triés puis envoyé en
déchetterie au centre de valorisation
mais quoi qu'il en soit là de son du
jour c'est lilian trois ans et demi qui
nous la donne alors il faut j'étais
pour finir ce journal la petite phrase
politique du jour elle est signée de
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation de
l'économie sociale aujourd'hui député
des yvelines benoît hamon qui a taclé
donc une nouvelle fois le président
françois hollande dans une interview
accordée à paris match publié
aujourd'hui il estime ce dernier
incapable de figurer au second tour de
la présidentielle en 2017 il demande une
nouvelle fois une inflexion plus social
à de la politique menée par les
socialistes par le gouvernement il
estime que bon nombre des solutions
portées par la gauche n'ont toujours pas
été tenté alors que s'approche bien
évidemment le congrès des socialistes au
mois de juin qui devrait être plutôt
tendue la veille des élections
régionales de la fin de l'année ce sera
en décembre prochain un journal demain
jeudi aux mêmes horaires un replay sur
notre site internet pour toutes nos
éditions et nos différents reportages
tout de suite ces kiosques
l'hebdomadaire de la culture présenté
préparé par 4 x de l'atome belle soirée